-Jason, since you play Aquaman,
I wanted to challenge you
to a "water war."
We'll play the card game war,
but if you lose the hand,
you get a --
[ Laughter ]
You get a pint of water
in the face, okay?
We have five glasses of water.
The first one to throw all five
glasses on their opponent wins
and gets to water-cannon
the loser.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Lots of ways to get wet,
but only one way to win.
[ Laughter ]
-You love it.
-I know, I know.
-There's only one way to win!
-All right.
Are you ready for this?
-I'm ready.
-Do you trust the cards?
Do you want to shuffle?
Are you all good?
Do you trust me?
-I trust you.
[ Laughter ]
-One, two --
-Oh, hold on, hold on.
Hold on, hold on, hang on,
hang on, hang on.
Let's just do it.
Ready?
-One, two, three, flip.
-Ah!
-I won.
[ Laughter ]
Now I'm not sure
if I wanted to win.
Do you want to win?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wore my hat, Jimmy.
-All right, all right.
Roots, I'm going to run out
of here if things get nasty.
One, two, three, play.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, it's great having
you on the show.
[ Laughter ]
I love "Frontier,"
it's fantastic.
I like the beginning --
I also like the end is great.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
One, two, three, flip.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
-I think this is like
Aquaman loves water?
-I don't know what's going on.
It's not rigged.
I'm so sorry to do this to you.
-It better not be rigged, Jimmy.
-I swear.
I swear, it's not, right?
If it was, I had nothing
to do with it.
There is a writer that's
running around the hall --
-Throw it in my face!
-All right, yeah, yes, sir!
-Now!
-Yes, sir!
-Again!
-Yes, okay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
One, two, three, flip.
-Okay.
I'm good with this.
-Sorry, sorry, sorry.
[ Applause ]
Come on!
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to get
your suit wet.
-Yeah.
Well, okay.
Just a little sticky down there.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
One, two, three.
Oh, yeah.
-That was like --
I mean, that was like --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Go ahead, go ahead.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Here we go!
-Oh, I would have won that one.
-Oh, trust me, I know
what it feels like.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, trust me.
-There it is.
-For the win!
One, two, three, come on.
Oh.
-Aah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
There we go.
-Is there more water
in your glass?
[ Laughter ]
I got basically slapped
in the face
with water just there.
-It's a talent.
You gonna kick my ass?
Oh [ Bleep ].
[ Cheers ]
Oh!
It's the last one, man.
[ Cheers ]
-One, two, three!
Flip!
What?!
-Boom!
Boom!
[ Band plays ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That went up --
That one went up my nose.
That one went up
my nose right there.
All right.
Here we go.
-All right.
-One, two, three.
I hate you!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Boom!
Bam!
There we are, baby!
[ Laughter ]
Here we are.
Hey, this is amazing.
-This is for the win.
I love you, buddy.
-I love you, too.
Let's do this.
-One, two, three!
Oh!
No, you know what that means?
-This is amazing!
That means, take out
your pitcher.
You got a pitcher down there.
Now, pick three,
and when we flip over that,
that is the
all-time winner.
Pitcher, glass, water cannon.
-One, two, three, right?
-The fourth card.
-Ready?
-One card, two card, three,
and then flip this one.
-Oh, Jimmy.
-This is war, baby!
-No matter what happens,
I love you.
-I love you too, man.
-Bam!
Oh, my God!
Double [ Bleep ] War!
[ Laughter and cheers ]
Has there ever been
a double war?
-There's never been
a double war!
-You can't do that.
-Yes!
-All right.
-Now what happens?
-We have to do it again.
One, two, three.
-All right, okay.
-One, two -- three --
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Drum roll ]
[ Cheers ]
Woo, hoo, hoo, hoo!
-The winner!
Jason Momoa.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Frontier" is on
Netflix right now.
The war on drugs is next.
Stick around.
Here, you can shoot me
with this if you want.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What do you do?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Dude, let's go
to commercial!
[ Cheers and applause ]